tombola et comme tous les fans ils vont
jamais c'est le problème c'est nous ces
salariés ne savent plus à quel saint se
vouer
ils veulent que plateforme de travail
entachée par le décès d'un de leurs
collègues vieux 2017 soit impérativement
sécurisé finalement nous on a une
réponse de la ctm sauf que cette réponse
elle est trop vague et nous bloque de la
mesure ils nous disent qu'ils ne veulent
pas faire de travaux et considérer que
l'accident qui s'est produit le 22
juillet 2017
c'est un accident de la route aux la
jeune il était à son travail ce n'est
pas un accident de la route c'est un
accident de travail
aujourd'hui il analyse cette réponse
négative de la septième en présence du
gérant de la station le problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est que la ctm par écrit
nous dit qu'elle ne va pas aucun aucune
disposition supplémentaires pour assurer
la protection des salariés
donc on se retrouve bloquée et donc
aujourd'hui on essaie de voir qu'est ce
qu'on peut en ce point comme mouvement
offert sans trop nous est navré n'est
pas positif et des dispositions de
sécurité nouvelles qui viennent
renforcer la sécurité de nos salariés
lundi dernier les salariés ont perturbé
les travaux d'enrobés de cette route
nationale au niveau de l'aéroport du
lamentin
ils restent déterminés nous allons dans
l'intensité
- sont des réponses plus elle serait
intense il souhaite donc qu'un mur de
protection soient dressés entre le
national et la station que des bandes de
google soit placé juste à l'entrée de la
voie et qu'un panneau de signalisation
limitant la vitesse à 30 km heure soit
implanté à l'entrée de cette voie de
décélération